c'est un indicateur qui nous permet
d'estimer la fréquence l'intensité de
circulation du virus
département par département pour
constituer cet indicateur nous nous
sommes appuyés santé publique france la
direction générale de la santé s'appuie
sur un indicateur bien connu maîtrise et
fiable robuste et qui était extrêmement
sensible qui est la part des patients
qui s'adresse aux urgences de l'hôpital
pour une suspicion d'infection à
coronavirus exprimé en pourcentage sur
la carte
ces données sont actualisées
quotidiennement sur le site data.gouv.fr
elles sont issues du réseau de presque
700 services d'urgence de france et
permettent donc de comptabiliser plus de
90% des passages aux urgences
c'est une source d'information
importante département par département
et qui est le reflet de la circulation
du virus vous avez envers dans la
tonalité des passages aux urgences les
endroits où la part liée à des
suspicions d'infection à coronavirus pas
forcément des cas d'ailleurs confirmé
des suspicions de qourna virus est
inférieur à 6% venir je le redis s'il ya
moins de 6% qui vont aux urgences des
hôpitaux d'un département pour suspicion
coronavirus le département apparaît
alors en verre si c'est entre six et dix
pour cent des patients qui vont aux
urgences pour une suspicion de
coronavirus le département apparaît
aujourd'hui en orange et en rouge c'est
lorsqu'il y a plus de 10 % des
consultations aux urgences des hôpitaux
d'un département qui sont liés en sus
fixe sur une suspicion d'infection à
coronavirus quelques précautions à
nouveau des usages très pratique vous
pouvez être surpris notamment de voir
que dans la région grand est le
haut-rhin et le bas-rhin apparaissent
d'anvers parce que vous le savez ces
deux départements ont subi de plein
fouet la première vague la grande vague
épidémique qui a touché notre pays au
mois de mars et au mois d'avril
pourquoi ces départements sont en verre
non pas parce que la pression
hospitalière il serait faible vous
verrez sur la carte suivante mais parce
que nous constatons qu actuellement
parmi les passages aux urgences un
nombre limité sont liées à l'infection
au coronavirus ce qui veut dire que sur
les sept derniers jours
activité épidémique kiko vides il y est
considéré comme maîtrisé ou en tout cas
plus faible que les normes et que les
seuils que nous avons fixés al'inverse
vous avez un département qui apparaît en
rouge dans le sud ouest de la france qui
correspond au lot qui a l'air comme ça
assez isolé en rouge parce que il y à un
certain nombre de passages aux urgences
qui ont été motivées par une suspicion
de corona d'élus ce qui ne veut pas
nécessairement dire que l'activité
épidémique a vocation à rester intense
ou à demeurer réel dans ce département
alors pour pouvoir affiner ces données
nous allons nous appuyer sur d'autres
indicateurs qu'on appelle des signaux
plus faible mais qui sont des
indicateurs importants comme par exemple
les remontées d'informations qui nous
viennent des médecins généralistes avec
ce qu'on appelle le réseau sentinelles
qui est un réseau de médecins impliqués
dans les politiques de santé publique et
comme pour chaque épidémie notamment
pour la grippe
ils sont capables de nous faire remonter
des informations
vont aussi affiner ses données avec le
nombre de tests positifs qui peuvent
être réalisées dans ce département donc
je le redis ce n'est pas parce que le
lot apparaît rouge aujourd'hui qu'il
sera forcément rouge au 11 mai et ce
n'est pas parce que bas-rhin à paris
vers aujourd'hui qu'il serait
nécessairement vert pour ce critère or
11 mai la deuxième carte qui va
apparaître sur votre écran
elle présente le niveau de tension le
niveau d'occupation le niveau de
saturation des réanimations liés à des
hospitalisations de malades atteints du
coronavirus et là vous allez être ça
vous paraît sans doute plus familier
heures vori aux informations que vous
avez acquises au cours de cette épidémie
à savoir que vous avez un grand quart
nord-est qui apparaît en rouge
d'abord vous dire que pour cet
indicateur raisonner à l'échelle du
département ne ferait pas sens il faut
raisonner plutôt à l'échelle des régions
puisque comme nous l'avons vu dans la
région grand est
lorsque l'épidémie frappe un territoire
ont fait appel alors à toutes les
réanimations à tous les établissements
de santé publics et privés de la région
concernée pour être capable de sauver
des vies et d'accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
les malades ainsi vous avez un certain
nombre de régions qui apparaissent en
rouge parce que plus de 80 % des lits de
réanimation ils sont occupés par des
malades atteints du coronavirus lorsque
les régions lorsque les territoires
apparaissent tant orange c'est que 60 à
80 % des lits de réanimation sont encore
à date d'aujourd'hui occupés par des
malades atteints du grenat virus enfin
lorsque les territoires apparaissent
tant vert sur la carte
c'est que moins de 60 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des formes
graves de coronavirus c'est un bon
indicateur de la tension deux
des réanimations ce qu'il faut que vous
compreniez c'est que tant qu'il y a
beaucoup de malades dans les
réanimations tant que les animations
n'ont pas retrouvé un rythme de
croisière normale
nous devons faire particulièrement
attention au moment où le vent le
confinement parce que s'il y avait une
reprise épidémique est bien très
rapidement nous pourrions atteindre une
saturation des réseaux
et ça c'est évidemment ce que nous
cherchons à éviter le plus possible à
nouveau ces données elles sont
disponibles accessibles
réactualisé animation très régulier en
rythme de croisière où ces données sont
sensibles elles sont importantes à
suivre et à nouveau ces données ni lui
ce truc-là situer
sion au jour d'aujourd'hui est pas la
situation au 11 mai elle est encore
susceptible d'évoluer même si concernant
ces données de saturation des
réanimations elle évolue forcément plus
lentement que les données de circulation
active du virus
et enfin vous avez une carte de synthèse
qui va apparaître une carte de synthèse
qui fait la synthèse de ces deux
principaux indicateurs avec des
territoires qui apparaissent en rouge
lorsque au moins un des indicateurs est
en rouge
avec des territoires qui apparaissent en
rouge lorsque au moins un des
indicateurs est en rouge pour le
département concerné des cartes des
départements qui vont apparaître en
verre lorsque tous les indicateurs sont
en verre dans les départements concernés
et puis encore des zones orange lorsque
on est entre deux il n'y a pas
d'indicateur rouge mais il ya au moins
un indicateur orange c'est à dire que où
il ya une pression épidémique une
circulation active du virus qui est
encore au dessus de l'attendu où les
réanimations sont à un niveau de
saturation qui est au dessus des normes
et des seuils que nous avons fixés le
premier ministre l'a dit au moment de
lever le confinement il y aura des
départements verts et les départements
rouge mais considérant le fait que nous
ne sommes pas dans la prévision du 11
mai mais de l'état actuel des choses
aujourd'hui que nous sommes amenés à
affiner ses données à les regarder
évoluer
jour après jour jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine prochaine nous avons maintenu
des zones orange qui sont des zones qui
ont vocation à basculer d'ici au 11 mai
ou en verre qui la pression épidémique
se réduit parce que vous restez chez
vous si le les lits de réanimation
arrive à retrouver un peu plus
d'amplitude ou a basculé en rouge si
d'aventuré la circulation du virus de
bêtes s'accentuer ou aussi il y avait à
nouveau ou encore trop de malades dans
les services de réanimation
donc ces cartographies encore une fois
ne sont que des indicateurs qui guident
les décisions
ils sont affinés par d'autres
indicateurs